let's just talk about the show first
Lord because who comes up with something
just so damn crazy their dance shows but
this is really taking it to life it's
like the Roman Colosseum of Dance
thank you so much that was a beautiful
description that'll be our tagline in
the subtitle next season you could you
come up with this idea
it's from many brilliant minds so many
brave minds came together kwibi being
one of them so I'm so excited about
cookie right now as the brand new mobile
platform that is so innovative in terms
of like how they thought not how to
create for the consumer and how the
consumer could consumes so being any
show any movie any reality tea or TV
they don't use that anymore quippy you
are able to watch vertically or
horizontally just depending on like how
you put your phone they're able to
digest them and quick delicious bites to
keep them short they keep you sweet just
like their hosts and it's it's such a
good it's such a good way to like be
able to escape for a little bit and just
enjoy yourself okay this show people
come on their dance routine all of a
sudden the floor starts moving which is
a lot by the way it slack already is
like cirque du soleil
cop where they move the floor okay all
of a sudden things start swinging has
anybody gotten hurt we had so many
emergency vehicles on set didn't use one
none
it we insured such an amazing save set
there is a massive foam pit that's like
I even know the proper measurements
don't quote me on this but it's like it
looks like it's about a hundred feet
wide is 11 feet you know we might have
lost couple people in there I'm not
sharing them and didn't see where when
they cleaned out but it was really
really safe and really really fun and
the dancers had a good time too which
I'm so surprised because as a dancer
your body is your instrument that's like
rolling it around around anyway I will
hate were there tears and frustrations
when people because I saw some people in
the pit like what just happened yeah we
had one girl that was terrified of
heights
I relate my short and she was crying in
the pit afterwards but it was like happy
tears like we helped her overcome her
fear so she chose this one for sure so
yeah here's the tears of like am I'm
just my shopping become world painful no
she did she is in every intro now it's
this adorable girl she's blonde she's in
the cubes and she goes ah so now using
every promo shot good quick what are the
perils of that moving stage for you
we have you gone out there yes
six-inch heels that's Talan right there
okay speak it up it's insane I don't
know how they do it they like refuse to
move the ground whenever I'm up there
because of course they put a little hose
six-inch heels and a skirt for a dance
show but everybody else is up there with
like sneaks on and sweatpants but still
it is so hard why I tell you it lifts
entirely it like I don't know what
measurements I don't know science like
that but like it looks like a 45 degree
angle it's for sure like italicized from
where the judges sit my like yes judges
and I whoo
they're so fun to you gotta check out
watch whoo all we have on the show it's
a lot it's a lot that comes out them and
flying balls to massive like we have a
mess globe yeah I said there's literally
a mattress with my face on it I did not
ask for that
I'm real humble but there is a hundred
dollar bill with my face on it I saw
that hopefully I saw that hit some come
on God spanked with my face yeah you
answered that call it and then you
rolled over
I was polite hope like contestant man I
will say I'm at the point where I'm like
I wish my house is haunted so I had
somebody to talk to her hanging out with
I'm like should I summon up a friend
with the Ouija board I don't know we
could get there
life has been good I am so blessed to be
able to do what I do and be able to do
it from home and you know I'm just
hoping that everyone is out there saying
safe and sayings somewhat sane and if
you're not you're probably turning it
into a content somehow it's nice it's
nice to see like it's okay to lose it so
came that be okay and it's okay to like
go live and look real rough because it
lets the rest of the world in and it's
kind of beautiful but they're not but I
love that are you quarantine alone
you're just there by yourself making
creating content doing your thing okay
here's what I want to know especially
since I have a house full of children
have you come close to inviting someone
over because I've come close to putting
people out right I'm a house full of
child so I would love to handle myself
like I realize you know I just I don't
shut up like I just stopped by about a
so it's a lot to put up with but uh you
know I have invited what they over I
have on physically distance walks though
and you're suppose to say six feet apart
but I I do a whole like ten speaks I'm
just bitter while talking so I I stay as
far away as possible to keep my friend
as safe as possible but I've been out a
few of those and it's nice make sure to
get out good son
feels good we're seeing this whole thing
where people are hating while they're
like in quarantine no I'm not that's the
answer as I say like would you have
advice for people like what can you do
in quarantine I write I need the
encouragement to step out and go do it
or not step out like stay in and go do
it I was close to starting a show on IG
live out of creativity but also that's
porosity effect that's weird to just go
live with any willing bachelors who want
to settle down together separate and
that would be so easy it would be it
would be crazy if someone just like
watches you go on a blind date somebody
that you guest in on your
I'm pitching yourself we could work on
that we don't work on that let me start
that now okay okay now last time I saw
you you wouldn't tell me what you were
working on with little Smith you guys
did do a little bits off what else do
you have cooking with a Big Willie I had
no idea that that was coming cuz he
created this whole show called mom on
snapchat
he is so the most generous with his
journey and his advice in his word it
was so amazing because he commended me
for somebody that he studied online and
and to understand social media and that
blew my mind because I've been studying
him in terms of like acting and without
how to be Will Smith I just want to do
it so we do a little dance off he's
learning tick tock right now I make like
17 tick tock today and I post it's hard
man it's much too makeup control I'm
gonna be like go look at me like that I
thought did you were just they were just
flying out they were just blocking
because I watched your makeup tutorials
and those seemed have been funded that
was a fun I background right here but
over here we got all the makeup to the
side let it's me it lets me create in a
new way that I haven't before and I
always suggest during this time to you
know check out something new try
something new every day mix up your
schedule so you know don't just stack
have you heard from James drawings did
you were stepping on his neck yeah
correct
I was he commented below and let me know
that get off me so I did oh he's okay
everything is working okay everything's
working as esophagus it's not how close
were you to cutting your own hair no I
was not funny now I got my hair's pretty
short so I got a haircut right before I
with this okay and I've been good ever
since oh I have it
oh you ain't you also can't post my hair
dye I tried already so I was that close
but uh this makes hair guy to come in
and hook it up paradise a hair dye so
thinking like purple no kick then I
looked the Met Gala is canceled and how
are you handling you jump to you no one
handles that upset man is the sad galas
mad gala I wish I mean it's such an
amazing like uniting night where
everybody comes and just expresses
themselves creatively and I just feels
free and has fun especially last year
with like the campaign that was so
exciting to see people like literally
decorate their souls I was living you
were close he flew in Lady Gaga had 18
dresses like it was amazing I wish I
could witness it in person again but
it'll be it'll be a good time when it
does and this year's theme was about
time so what what it actually doesn't
happen
about time how was that and what advice
would you give to others who all of a
sudden you know they England one of
these famous I want to be things and
then you're like oh you famous now I
would say give yourself the break that
you need because you are your own
battery you'll it all comes from your
core it all comes from who you are your
foundation so make sure you are treating
that right that you are you know making
the choices for yourself that if you're
really truly committed to a dream that
you devote yourself to it and maybe
don't go out and your insanity comes
from you know wanting change and then
not doing anything to change you have
done these incredible things from you
know going off foreign lands with
Michelle Obama it was 2016 when I
interviewed President Barack Obama
mm-hmm and that was my audition for mrs.
Michelle Obama I did that I'm just
living now I don't know I thought my
purpose was dining I was like okay I'm
gonna go up in the beam of light but
that was I'm still here so there's some
work to do
and I don't know I'm just I'm writing
the way that hasn't right now right now
it's just me it's me and my mirror that
I'm working with and that's that's all
we got right now
but we'll see we'll see where the world
exist something actually kept this well
when I interviewed President Barack
Obama
these are Hershey's Kisses from the
White House honey
[Music]